they get so excited about the modeling
that they forget that actually we have
to like make value or there is no reason
that we exist we're just becoming an
expense
so i've had to have those conversations
before i know this is exciting but there
is a balance between figuring out a
really cool way of doing this
and giving real value without taking too
much time
those are those are conversations and
depending on the person
there are just people that would love to
be in academia but are not
so some of the phd
phds i have
had
more of that with
and i think that's just like you've been
in school forever that is what you do
so
but
oh you know what i had one other thought
because we're still talking um
getting people to present their results
is useful
but
i've had to coach multiple people being
like okay remember who's in the audience
you're talking to the ceo is he going to
care about this no
he cares about his financials showing
this this and this so how can you relate
this back
instead of spoon feeding it though like
you got to get them to actually
understand how to do that
which takes time